[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم وسط التحذيرات متزايده
من الاضرار البيئيه والصحيه فرق الانقاذ
تكافح للعثور على جثث ضحايا الفيضانات
شرقيه ليبيا وزير الصحه بالحكومه المكلفه
من البرلمان يؤكد انه لا خوف من انتشار
الاوبئه
واضرار تصيب نحو 70% من البنيه التحتيه في
درنه
وفي المغرب استمرار جهود اغاثه المنكوبين
جراء الزلزال رئيس الحكومه يقول ان
التاهيل سيركز على تقويه البنيه التحتيه
في الاقاليم المنكوبه والحكومه تعلن
استئناف الدراسه في الاقاليم الخمسه التي
ضربها الزلزال
اذربيجان تبدا عمليه عسكريه في اقليم
كاراباخ وتعلن توجيه ضربات لقوات ومواقع
عسكريه ارمينيه ارمينيا تنفي وجود وحدات
عسكريه لها في كاراباخ وتطالب بتدخل مجلس
الامن وقوات حفظ السلام الروسيه وموسكو
تدعو لتنفيذ الاتفاقيات بين ارمينيا
واذربيجان بخصوصك
ضمن صفقه تبادل السجناء بين طهران و
واشنطن بواسطه قطريه خمسه امريكيين وافراد
اسرهم يصلون الى الولايات المتحده عبر
الدوحه وايرانيان ليصلان طهران قادمين من
الدوحه والمتحدث باسم الحكومه الايرانيه
يقول ان الاموال الايرانيه في المصارف
القطريه باتت تحت تصرف البنك المركزي
الايراني في امان الله